df 1 20 heures avec jean claude bourret
henry miller est mort il avait 88 ans
c'est à paris qu'il avait écrit son
premier roman le tropique du cancer
présidentielle les radicaux de gauche
désignent michel crépeau face aux
socialistes le mrg a tenu à marquer son
originalité
les médecins et la sécurité sociale le
syndicat majoritaire décident de
boycotter la nouvelle convention pétrole
inquiétudes chez les européens ils
redoutent une nouvelle augmentation du
prix du pétrole
à la veille de la conférence des pays
producteurs qui s'ouvre demain à alger
roland garros encore borg et pour la
cinquième fois
il a battu guerroumi attise par 6 4 6 1
et 6 2 madame mademoiselle monsieur
bonsoir
et oui toute petite formalité pour bjorn
borg il a été obligé de taper dans une
balle de tennis pendant 106 minutes
exactement afin de remporter la finale
du tournoi de roland garros face à lui
gayraud light is a fait le maximum mais
ce n'était pas suffisant pour battre ni
même pour inquiéter le champion suédois
georges dominique le champion suédois
qui tour à tour à et légumiers un
équatorien français un hongrois anita
lien et un américain sont tombés sous la
raquette de gerulaitis trois américains
un tchèque et à polonais
106 minutes de match autrement dit une
heure 46 minutes ce fut donc une finale
assez rapidement expédiée mais si elle
manque a quelquefois d'émotion elle nous
valut quelques moments de choix ici par
exemple au cours du deuxième set
et puis regardez tout de suite quelques
instantanés plutôt cocasse il faut que
borg pas céder sa raquette pour que le
suédois esquisse un tout léger sourire
est ce la puissance du service sous le
choc au sol peu importe remarquons
jusque board aurait fait un excellent
footballeur reprise de volée
service gerulaitis ça a touché le filet
et comme le let est signalée un peu
tardivement
l'américain va montrer aux juges de
filet comment faire pour être un peu
plus réveillé
gerulaitis malchanceux préfère cette
fois joué les pantins pour oublier ses
malheurs
mais l'américain n'est pas simplement un
comique
la preuve ici avec une balle de 3 1 au
cours du deuxième set
mais la belle suivante ne fut pas aussi
réussi rien ça fait quinze ans que tu
joues espèce de et borgne continue la
défaite de guéroult les ti se précise
alors la raquette en enfer et puis pour
terminer balle de match et tout de suite
l'un des coups favori de borg le passing
shot
voilà 6 4 6 1 6 2 le score est en prime
ça n'a pas été aussi facile les jeux ont
été très disputés
mais j'ai surtout réussi à gagner grâce
aux balles décisives votre train est
cochée à gauche cinq fois vainqueur
comme borg
depuis tout à l'heure moi mon le célèbre
prix du jockey-club l'un des sommets de
la saison des courses hippiques a eu
lieu cet après midi à chantilly sous un
beau soleil et la 139e épreuve du nom a
été marqué par une surprise andré théron
en effet jean-claude c'est une surprise
mais c'est aussi un record en triomphant
à la cote de 54 contre 1 le vainqueur
policeman c'est le nom du poulain a
établi le record décote dans le prix du
jockey club
mais outre ce record nous avons assisté
à deux exploits
le premier concerne un homme willie
garson un écossais peu avare puisqu'il a
remporté depuis mercredi dernier le
derby d'epsom les oaks d'epsom et cet
après-midi le jockey club
enfin second exploit l'actif du cheval
de police mène celui là j'avoue avoir
rarement vu un cheval qui prenait la
tête aux grandes écuries c'est à dire
dans le dernier tournant et qui
parvenait à ses fins repoussant toutes
les attaques de ses adversaires mais des
attaques
il y en eut que nous voici précisément
grandes écuries et cet hybride
iman il est talonné déjà par policeman
que nous allons reconnaître très
facilement son jockey willie garson ne
porte une casaque rouge et voici ce
policeman qui va prendre la tête devant
hybride qui est sur ses fins derrière
lui nous apercevons dont savary
arguments et speed bas ce speed basse
une casaque blanche le long de la corde
nous sommes toujours dans le dernier
tournant nous avons arrivée au château
et bientôt ce sera l'entrée de la ligne
droite il va se passer peu de chose à
vrai dire dans la ligne droite en tête
la casaque rouge est déjà quelque chose
d'insolite policeman est en tête et en
seconde position nous avons dont aldo
c'est à dire le second pensionnaire de
l'entraîneur charley milbank et qui pour
l'instant est premier et second du derby
mais attention à l'extérieur une casaque
verte celle de la gac emporté par yves
saint martin on peut penser un bref
instant d'ailleurs je le demande ride on
peut penser un bref instant qu'il ne va
faire qu'une bouchée de police man mais
il n'en est rien nous changeons nos
plans mais ça ne change pas grand-chose
à la sphère en tête policeman en seconde
position toujours xhaka pour qu'ils ne
refais rien et les autres sont perdus en
route le troisième sera providentiel un
autre favori de la course et le
quatrième dans l 2 le vainqueur
appartient à un anglais qui est
naturalisé monégasque il est entraîné
par charley milbank anglais lui aussi
citoyen d'honneur de cagnes sur mer ou
dans l d'eau avait très bien couru et
même gagné d'ailleurs cet hiver les
rapports du tiercé peut-être non sachant
simplement que ce tiercé et le 13 le 1
et le 5 et soyons patients pour les
rapports s'il vous plaît
nouveau candidat pour les élections
présidentielles l'année prochaine michel
crépeau qui a été désigné par le congrès
des radicaux de gauche michel crépeau à
47 ans et il a également été reconduit
dans ses fonctions de président du
émerger bruno masure pexiora bien sûr un
candidat socialiste
un deux ou plusieurs candidats
écologistes et puis il y a depuis ce
matin à michel crépeau et cela fait
beaucoup de monde pour se partager les
voix de la gauche non communiste en
france
michel crépeau le sait bien il n'est pas
candidat à tout prix et encore moins
suicidaire je ferai toujours dit il
passée la possibilité de victoire de la
gauche sur les intérêts de la boutique
radical de gauche
il s'agit en effet surtout pour michel
crépeau de faire connaître ses idées de
peser sur l'échiquier politique et
d'être en position de force pour
négocier éventuellement avec le candidat
socialiste l'obligé à user d'un langage
nouveau qui seule permettra la victoire
de la gauche ce que j'ai dit est ce que
j'ai seulement dit c'est que le langage
que tient officiellement aujourd'hui le
parti socialiste le langage du projet
socialiste parce qu'il se situe
directement dans la filiation de ce que
nous avons dit depuis 20 ans n'est pas
susceptible de créer ce fait nouveau et
ce profond mouvement d'opinion qui
conduirait la gauche à la victoire
voilà ce que j'ai dit est que c'est
probablement le langage tout différent
que la gauche tient dans les autres pays
d'europe qui permettrait d'assurer la
victoire de la gauche en france
alors ça non seulement je les dis mais
je le répète parce que j'en suis
profondément convaincu 2000 jeunes
communistes étaient réunis à saint denis
cet après midi près de paris à
l'occasion de la fête organisée par leur
journal l'avant garde et à cette
occasion charles fiterman députés du
parti communiste a évoqué la perspective
historique de la révolution
pour y arriver à la faire cette
révolution nous ne sommes pas seuls ici
en france
regardez ce qui se passe dans le monde
aujourd'hui le socialisme n'est plus
seulement une utopie
il est devenu réalité pour le tiers de
l'humanité
combien y at-il de chômeurs en union
soviétique en pologne ou en rd la zéro
il n'y en a pas
dans ces pays on manque de main d'oeuvre
combien cela coûte-t-il pour étudier
dans les pays socialistes réponse 0
c'est très bien je vois que vous
connaissez les réponses ça veut dire que
vous connaissez bien les pays
socialistes et je vous invite à faire
partager cette connaissance à des
milliers des dizaines et des centaines
de milliers d'autres jeunes de france
les médecins de la confédération des
syndicats médicaux français ont refusé
une nouvelle fois d'appliquer la
convention signée par un syndicat
minoritaire
la csmf représente en effet 80% des
médecins syndiqués et un médecin sur
deux elle a appelé ses adhérents à
appliquer les tarifs syndicaux mise en
vigueur depuis le 17 mars dernier
françois vaud a suivi cette assemblée
générale qui s'est déroulée dans une
salle de l'assemblée nationale
principales décisions prises fin
d'après-midi par la csmf
et si elle est suivie elle risque de
bloquer nouveau système ses adhérents
vont refuser de choisir entre les deux
secteurs proposées par la nouvelle
convention
car pour que cette nouvelle convention
soit applicable chaque médecin doit
choisir se déterminer où il choisit
d'appliquer les tarifs conventionnels ou
il choisi de fixer librement ses
honoraires or aujourd'hui la csmf
repousse ce choix
nous donnons aux médecins la consigne
formelle de ne pas répondre aux appels
des adhésions du zèle des caisses mais
au contraire d'envoyer aux syndicats
départementaux mais à tous les médecins
allemandes ont envoyé aux syndicats
départementaux les appels des
formulaires qu'ils recevront des quêtes
alors pour les assurés qu est ce que ça
va changer pour les assurés ça ne
changera rien car nous ne voulons pas
justement c'est une décision importante
notre assemblée générale qui a été
d'ailleurs très vous avez vu nombreuses
et danse nous voulons pas nuire aux
intérêts des assurés sociaux mais nous
continuerons à ignorer la convention
c'est à dire que des consignes qui sont
données ce sont les consignes syndicales
y compris en ce qui concerne les barèmes
d'honoraires la convention ne
connaissons pas alors une dernière
question si la caisse nationale
d'assurance maladie prend des sanctions
et bien chiche
l'aide est décidée par la l'ensemble des
syndicats ils s'étaient tous représentés
un engagement formel et solennel de tous
les syndicats départementaux
qu'immédiatement l'ensemble de la
profession serait solidaire des médecins
qui seraient victimes des sanctions à
condition bien sûr que la sanction soit
motivée par l'application d'une consigne
syndicale
en cas de sanction la ccms affirme
qu'elle utilisera tous les moyens y
compris la grève
en tout cas la grève administrative pour
empêcher la nouvelle convention de
fonctionner concorde continuera d'être
exploitée et cela bien au delà de 10 ans
est ce que monsieur joël le theule le
ministre des transports a déclaré à
europe 1 jean-françois deniau ministre
du commerce extérieur qui s'exprimait
sur la même antenne s'est déclaré
satisfait du règlement de bruxelles les
britanniques qui ne voulait rien payé
verseront 3 milliards et les français en
tenue 10% d'augmentation des prix
agricoles
monsieur yvon bourges le ministre de la
défense a réaffirmé aujourd'hui la
nécessité de maintenir une armée de
conscription et de renforcer la
contribution des réserves
monsieur yvon bourges a pris la parole
devant le 49e congrès de l'union
nationale des officiers de réserve
le corps du soldat inconnu d'indochine a
été inhumé ce matin au cimetière
national de notre dame de lorette aux
côtés du soldat inconnu d'algérie de
nombreux anciens combattants assisté à
cette cérémonie
auto au cours de laquelle monsieur
maurice plantier secrétaire d'état a
déclaré l'armée française en indochine
s'est montré digne des traditions de ses
aînés elle n'a à rougir ni de la manière
dont elle s'est battue ni des raisons de
combat 80 photographes de presse et
cameramen réunis hier à paris ont décidé
une semaine d'actions pour protester
contre les brutalités policières dont
ont été victimes deux photographes et un
motard de presse qui faisait tout
simplement leur métier en assurant un
reportage sur les manifestations
parisiennes des 4 et 5 juin derniers les
photographes et cameramen ont notamment
décidé de ne pas assurer de reportages
sur le conseil des ministres mercredi
deux mille personnes dont une vingtaine
de maires ont participé à la première
manifestation contre le stockage de
déchets radioactifs à saint priest la
prugne dans la loire il n'y a pas eu
d'incident deux morts et deux blessés
graves lors de l'épreuve automobile des
trophées d'auvergne près de clermont
ferrand de renault 5 se sont télescopés
ont franchi les glissières de sécurité
et ont fauché un groupe de spectateurs
l'écrivain américain henry miller est
mort hier en californie sa première
oeuvre tropique du cancer publié en 1934
avait fait scandale et avait d'ailleurs
été interdite pendant 26 ans aux états
unis
adam saunier fils d'un tailleur henri
muller très célèbre écrivain américain
né à new york en 1891 il est une
jeunesse difficile il exerça des métiers
différents il fut peintre entre autres
comme vous le voyez et séjourna
longtemps à paris notamment de 1930 1938
que c'était moi ça va en général on
écrit par les choses comme on parle
et moi j'ai toujours écrit comme un
parent et la bisexuelle ou me sens d'une
grande partie de notre vie et je n'ai vu
aucune raison de ne pas écrire là dessus
c'était de mon naturel pour moi parce
que je décris mes expériences ce moment
ce n'est pas des romans que j'écris ou
délits d'imagination cette odeur et
toujours
ma vie ce qui s'est passé dans ma vie et
alors j'étais paca bond prochain
mendiants et en me sans emploi sa
médiane j'ai rencontré toutes sortes de
gens il me semble que c'est tout naturel
tout à gagner et et nature pour moi
l'amour c'est toujours la chose la plus
importante est cependant pour tours - je
vois pour l'homme ordinaire lockdown
pour tout le monde l'amour c'est la
chose principale mon avis oui c'est
l'amour
lavigne lavaur yale son oeuvre
littéraire commence avec tropique du
cancer en 1934
nous avons ensuite printemps noir
tropique du capricorne
souvenirs souvenirs sexus plexus oeuvre
d'un homme seul
ma carrière commencée à ma vie j'étais
désespéré avec marvin horna mari je n'ai
vu aucune chance pour moi là-bas il me
semble que toutes les femmes et vous
tous que j'ai fait comme métier vous
déjà des emplois en espagne n était hier
à succès 1
j'étais un raté complètement
or la dernière chose que je pouvais
faire c'était écrit
c'était une sorte de salut pour moi
d'écrire
s'il ya un conseil que vous donnez un
jeune écrivain un jeune artiste ne rien
faire de ne choisit pas d'être un
artiste un peu de chance we were ne peut
pas faire
ce métier jusqu'à allait désespérer
n'est ce pas essayer n'importe quoi
parce que c'est le maître le métier le
plus difficile y être reconnue n'est ce
pas saveurs évoquées font prendre
peut-être dix vingt années n'est ce pas
et comment vivre entre temps surprise
dans la communauté juive de france sait
le rabbin rené sirat qui est élu en
remplacement de monsieur jacob kaplan
ormes sur une estrade qui à 50 ans
n'était pas le favori y ont pensé que le
grand rabbin de strasbourg et du
bas-rhin succéderait au grand rabbin
kaplan dont il avait d'ailleurs le
soutien
le rabbin rené sirat est un juif
originaire d'afrique du nord il est élu
pour une durée de sept ans alors que le
rabbin kaplan avait été lue à vie en
janvier 55
le grand rabbin jacob kaplan a
maintenant 85 ans et il sera remplacé
par son successeur le 1er janvier
prochain
monsieur sirat et marié il est père de
trois enfants il enseigne l'hébreu à
l'institut des langues et civilisations
orientales
à noter que les 250 délégués des
communautés juives de france ont
proclamé dans un communiqué le
rattachement privilégié historiques et
religieux à l'état d'israël ce
communiqué exprime également le voeu que
le gouvernement français je cite cesse
d'être sourd aux protestations de la
communauté juive de france et adoptée
vis-à-vis du conflit du proche orient
une attitude plus juste le premier
ministre israélien monsieur begin a
énergiquement rejeté aujourd'hui la
condamnation d'israël par le conseil de
sécurité
une condamnation qui a fait suite aux
attentats commis contre les maires
arabes de cisjordanie et monsieur begin
a expliqué israël n'avait pas besoin de
la condamnation du conseil de sécurité
pour condamner lui même ces attentats
avec la dernière énergie et décidé d'en
châtier les coupables
l'embargo pétrolier des pays arabes
contre l'afrique du sud va être
renforcée c'est l'une des décisions
prises à alger lors du sommet de
l'organisation des pays arabes
exportateurs de pétrole
mais demain alger ce sera l'ouverture
officielle du sommet de l'opep le
ministre irakien du pétrole souhaite
faire bondir le prix du baril à 32
dollars
le point avec notre envoyé spécial à
alger lone haniel 8 tremble chaque fois
que l'opep se réunit ainsi à la veille
de ce 57e sommeil
g l'or qui est une valeur refuge par
excellence a commencé à flamber sur
toutes les places internationales que
redoutons des augmentations bien sûr or
depuis décembre 78 le prix du pétrole
brut importé a augmenté de près de 150%
les 13 pays de l'opep vont se réunir
dans ce très grand hôtel moderne qui
domine alger 400 journalistes sont déjà
arrivés
un millier de personnes ont été
mobilisées de la police au secrétariat
en passant par les ptt
tout était prévu même ce bloc
chirurgical l'ordre du jour les prix
leur indexation et le niveau de
production trois thèmes qui divisent
l'opep en deux camps d'un côté les
modérés avec à leur tête l'arabie
saoudite qui réclame une unification des
tarifs et un gel des prix pendant six
mois
de l'autre côté les durs avec à leur
tête l'algérie qui est pour la liberté
des prix et l'alignement du prix du gaz
avec celui du pétrole daisy hier dès le
début de la conférence de l'opep qui n'a
regroupé que quelques pays arabes
producteurs de pétrole
deux changements importants sur le
marché pétrolier ont été au centre du
débat
premièrement jamais les différences de
prix n'ont été aussi grande
le prix le moins cher celui de l'arabie
saoudite est de 28 dollars le baril le
plus cher celui de l'algérie est de 38
dollars le baril deuxièmement jamais les
consommateurs non stockés d'une façon
aussi importante de 16 % plus élevé que
l'an dernier
aussi le sommet de caracas en décembre
dernier a été celui de la division six
mois après le sommet d'alger sera
peut-être celui de la conciliation
mais avant même qu'il ne commence
certains participants en doute déjà dans
une interview à l'afp et à l'agencé
france presse le président iranien
monsieur bani sadr admis l'échec des
méthodes choisies par la révolution
iranienne
au bout de 15 mois l'iran n'a pas réussi
à conquérir son indépendance a dit le
président bani sadr qui a conclu s'il
n'y a pas de provocation américaines la
résolution du problème des otages est
proche
avec georges dominique maintenant la
suite de notre page sportive
d'abord une précision à propos de
l'accident d'automobile qui s'est
produit sur le circuit de charade prêté
à montferrand cet après-midi accident
grave qui a fait deux morts et plusieurs
blessés une précision du comité
d'organisation
les deux victimes jean claude bourret
sont des commissaires de course
voilà pour ce grave accident nous venons
cela dit au tennis après le tournoi des
as cet après midi à roland-garros s'est
disputé l'épreuve des internationaux de
france n'est junior est une bonne
nouvelle c'est un français henri leconte
qui s'est imposé en finale il a battu
l'espagnol tous en deux sets c'est 6 et
6 3 le compte n'a pas encore 17 ans il
est de vincennes jusqu'ici il avait
obtenu de bons résultats puisqu'il avait
été finaliste des championnats d'europe
cadets et dans la même catégorie
finalistes du célèbre tournoi américain
de lorànt ball bonne nouvelle également
pour les caisses de la fédération record
encore battu cette année 222 1000
spectateurs ont assisté à la quinzaine
de roland-garros les sentes au guichet
une recette d'un milliard et cent
millions de centimes
reste bien sûr à construire beaucoup de
cours pour répondre à une demande de
tennis qui est très très fort et à payer
les champions il a touché combien borg
220 mille fois je crois 22 millions de
centimes voilà mais enfin cela c'est
c'est ce qui se fait habituellement dans
les grands tournois il y à l'argent qui
les attire c'est la raison pour laquelle
ils viennent et à roland garros et qu'on
les verra dans quinze jours à wimbledon
et aux états unis
cela dit jean-claude trois sports de
ballon ont connu au cours de ce week-end
de leurs dénouements football volley
ball et handball en football 63e finale
de la coupe de france une finale qui a
été un peu ternie par un but marqué sur
coup franc un but surprise les orléanais
vous le constatez ont protesté les
attendait un coup de sifflet qui n'est
jamais arrivé 3 1 pour monaco qui a
battu en riant club de deuxième division
les monégasques de jean-petit
disputeront donc la coupe d'europe des
vainqueurs de coupes en balles les bleu
et blanc ici de sa mort ont enlevé leur
sixième titre de champion de france de
3e consécutivement en finale ils ont
battu gagné 26 à 22 une finale
parisienne
enfin tout à l'heure par dessus le filet
c'est l'équipe d'asnières cassis et de
succéder à elle-même comme championne de
france de volley-ball c'était l'ultime
week-end du tournoi des as et asnières
s'impose ici devant clamart puis cannes
et sa mort
enfin en cyclisme on peut dire que
bernard hinault a donc réussi la
première partie de son pari tour
d'italie tour de france et championnat
du monde il a remporté donc hier le giro
prochain programme de bernard hinault le
tour de l'aude puis les championnats de
france sur route
et puis très bientôt le départ du tour
de france qui est fixée au 26 juin
dimanche dernier dimanche après midi au
stade de colombes un français devenait
recordman du monde du saut à la perche
était thierry vigneron la perche bien
sûr étaient à l'honneur aujourd'hui au
cours des journées de sélection sur ce
même stade de colombes
reportage de pierre torre ont peut-être
record demande du monde et n'en être pas
pour autant maître chez soi c'est ce
qu'à vérifier cet après midi thierry
vigneron 5 mètre 75 dimanche à et donc
sur ce même sautoir et troisième
seulement de ces épreuves de sélection
avec un bond de 5 mètre soixante réussi
au 3e essai
bonne occasion pour jean michel bélot
seconde vignerons précisément la semaine
passée de s'installer à son tour sommet
de la spécialité après un début de
concours remarquable et 5 mètre soixante
ici qu'il sera seul à franchir au
premier essai mais il en restera là et
il sera encore deuxième philippe
houillon le meilleur l'an passé avec
abada jusqu alors assez discret cette
saison mais là un retour tonitruant 5
mètre soixante dix records personnels
troisième performance mondiale de tous
les temps réussi au 1er essai après un
début de concours plutôt laborieux
logique respectée donc au terme d'une
épreuve superbe où l'on regrettera bien
sûr l'absence de patrick abad a opéré
cette semaine et où le jeune ferreira
quatrième avec un bond de 5 mètres 55 a
confirmé sa place parmi les grands on se
demande si le besoin d'un ascenseur pour
rentrer chez lui il ya maintenant plus
de 29 heures que les premiers voiliers
de la 6ème transatlantique en solitaire
son parti de plymouth en angleterre 89
monocoques et multicoques reste en
course
la position de chacun d'entre eux est
déterminé quotidiennement par satellite
grâce au système argos
at on déjà une idée des voiliers qui ont
une chance d'être dans le peloton de
tête
la réponse de stéphane magnier alors ce
qui est intéressant c'est qu'on commence
à se faire une idée sur ce qui risque de
se passer dans les jours à venir sur
cette course sucre qu'on connaît surtout
c'est la situation météo actuelles
actuellement il ya une zone de beau
temps qui va des açores des îles des
açores le célèbre anticyclone des açores
et qui se prolonge jusqu'à l'europe et
qui provoque le beau temps plus que les
100 à l'heure actuelle à paris et dans
le reste de la france
il ya une autre zone de beau temps qui
se trouve sur le groenland et qui est
également un anticyclone car le beau
temps est toujours un anticyclone et ces
deux zones de boutons donc celle du nord
et celles du sud empêche les dépressions
qui sont génératrices de mauvais temps
et qui suivent en général la ligne noire
qui symbolise parcours des concurrents
empêche donc ce mauvais temps de venir
sur le parcours des concurrents et le
bouton favorise incontestablement les
multicoques
quand on parle de beau temps tout est
relatif car on se situe dans
l'atlantique nord et l'atlantique nord
est quand même une des mères les plus
durs
du globe donc les multicoques sont
actuellement en tête vous avez
l'américain philip wild qui est ici sur
de très très près par le français marc
pajot qui très légèrement plus au nord
suivi également de très près par un
autre français eric loizeau est un tout
petit peu plus loin derrière le canadien
michael burch l'anglais nick clegg et
olivier de kersauson le seul monocoque
qui soit actuellement dans les premières
places mais comme le vent qui souffle
actuellement contre les concurrents
pourraient bien changer et basculer vers
le nord dans les heures qui viennent
cette situation va encore plus avantagé
les multicoques donc sur les six
premiers du classement ou sept premiers
du classement général
vous avez six multicoques et il est très
vraisemblable que la victoire se joue
entre ces six multicoques là et que les
murs les monocoques n'ai aucune chance
de terminer dans les premiers de la
course dans les heures à venir
un télégramme qui me parvient de
washington monsieur edmond mosci
secrétaire d'état américain a déclaré he
tout à l'heure que les états unis ne
ferait aucune objection à une éventuelle
initiative de leurs alliés européens
en ce qui concerne le proche orient
s'ils étaient de nature constructive et
si elle ne s'appelait pas les
négociations tripartites la météo et
bien demain lundi des orages à l'est du
rhône et en corse encore des nuages sur
l'atlantique mais demain après midi le
soleil fera son apparition marqué sur la
moitié est du soleil également demain
après-midi en bretagne vue de satellites
ce matin à 10h l'europe du soleil était
plutôt tristounette beaucoup de nuages
sur l'angleterre la belgique le
luxembourg l'allemagne la suisse et bien
sûr la france comme vous pouvez le
constater seule l'espagne et l'italie
pouvait prétendre au bronzage
vers 23 heures c'est jacques books qui
vous présentera les dernières
informations bonsoir et merci